au démarrage elle la récupérer au bord
de la route elle essayait de boire dans
une flaque d'eau
alors c'est le parcours qui a été assez
difficile c'était un dimanche donc ma
mère appelle la Clinique Vétérinaire de
Gisors on lui dit il faut faire appel à
la police municipale la police
municipale bien sûr est fermée on tombe
sur le week-end du 8 mai elle se rend
toujours donc avec la chienne dans la
voiture dans un mauvais état
elles seront à la gendarmerie qui ne
peut rien faire donc tout ça le temps
passe et la panique
la chienne est un très mauvais état
puisqu'on apprendra qu'elle a été brûlée
à l'acide que les yeux les paupières ont
été scalpées donc des yeux très abîmés
je pense que vous pouvez à peu près
voilà le voir et heureusement notre
mairesse a réussi à avoir un rendez-vous
avec la clinique vétérinaire et là où
les soins ont pu être pris
alors le parcours effectivement il a été
un petit peu un peu compliqué pourquoi
parce que les cliniques refusent de
s'occuper des animaux puisque c'est pas
votre propre animal personne qui paye
d'accord voilà et là on est tout à fait
d'accord et à savoir que la clinique a
pris la chaîne en charge parce que notre
mairesse a fait une lettre d'urgence en
disant nous allons prendre les soins à
notre charge
sinon maman se retrouvait voilà avec
qu'est-ce que vous avez vu les blessures
elle était très choquée c'est choquant
vraiment c'est choquant c'est pas c'est
pas le chien qu'on retrouve au bord là
elle était dans un état je vous dis elle
elle devait avoir très soif elle est en
train de de lécher une petite flaque
d'eau de pluie elle est à bout de force
alors vous l'avez récupéré chez vous ce
moment tu ne sais pas passer comme prévu
à la maison voilà jusqu'au mercredi ou
là après
Élodie est arrivé chez vous alors elle
est très gentille elle est très gentille
comme prévu ce qui s'est passé alors à
la maison j'ai des animaux mais on l'a
isolé ce que j'ai un mal bon c'est une
femelle bref
on l'a isolé on lui a donné des soins et
très câline très gentil
c'est pas
rébellionné on a pas eu de souci
d'accord alors saint-amonte de la
Fondation assistance aux animaux et on
veut ok la possibilité que la chienne
est utilisée pour des combats de chiens
voilà alors là c'est on l'a su par
rapport quand elle est arrivée chez
Elodie
c'est vous donc il y avait c'est chez
vous que qui est la chienne est allé
après c'est ça en fait
pas réellement en fait mercredi moi j'ai
contacté Aurélie pour pouvoir récupérer
la chaîne parce que je voulais l'adopter
parce que quand j'ai vu tout ça j'ai
voulu récupérer cette chaîne et donc
j'étais la chercher mercredi soir et
sachant que chez moi bon j'ai beaucoup
d'animaux et j'ai deux chiens donc avec
mon mari on a voulu faire les
présentations et en fait quand elle a vu
mes chiens elle s'est mise dans un état
pas possible à vouloir les attaquer donc
bon bah j'ai vu que c'était pas possible
et que je pourrais pas moi la garder
donc pour la nuit
comme la maman d'auréline pouvait pas la
récupérer elle a été donc dormir chez la
mairesse et le lendemain matin moi j'ai
été la récupérer pour je l'ai gardé je
travaille aussi à la mairie moi de mon
j'avoue je suis secrétaire et je l'ai
récupéré je l'ai gardé avec moi dans le
bureau toute la journée jusqu'à ce que
l'association enfin la Fondation
assistance aux animaux viennent à
chercher à 4 heures
vous avez tout de suite vu les blessures
c'est choquant j'étais les récupérer
avec mon mari et mon fils de 8 ans et
votre fils a dû être extrêmement choqué
c'est extrêmement choqué on a été choqué
c'était dur à regarder et à côté de ça
pour cette chaîne c'est un amour j'avais
voulu adopter ce film donc vous l'avez
récupéré et vous êtes dit je vais la
garder j'ai voulu la garder après je me
suis dit qu'il fallait faire un test
avec mes chiens à moi et malheureusement
enfin c'est pas possible c'était les
mettre en danger tous les trois donc
voilà je sais que c'est pas possible et
donc le jeudi midi aussi elle a été
récupérée par une famille qui veut
l'adopter donc elle a été faire un essai
chez eux ça s'est très bien passé donc
la famille souhaite adopter cette chaîne
donc on a tout on a informé la Fondation
assistance aux animaux et donc
normalement cette chaîne sera bien
récupérée par cette famille à la fin de
ses soins alors
où est-ce qu'on en sait plus sur les
propriétaires du chien à la base c'est
ça je crois que c'est un mystère non il
y a une a été porte donc le déposé à la
gendarmerie mais pour l'instant
on ne peut pas la retracer on peut pas
remonter la filière pour savoir si elle
appartenait à quelqu'un il y a qui et
par ailleurs il y a une enquête qui a
été qui a été ouverte la Fondation a
porté plainte pour SEVIS grave acte de
cruauté abandon volontaire d'un animal
domestique apprivoisé au captif c'est
auprès de la gendarmerie de
Chaumont-en-Vexin et les investigations
se poursuivent c'est le parquet de
Beauvais qui a récupéré l'affaire si je
dis pas de notice c'est ça et puis bah
nous on a essayé de enfin avec mon mari
on l'a mis sur tous les réseaux sociaux
possibles on a fait ce qu'on a pu pour
que cette histoire de spectateurs vont
peut-être reconnaître le Christ
en plus ça faisait plusieurs jours juste
ce chien qu'est-ce qui s'est passé parce
que c'est vrai que on entend plein de
choses donc il est l'acide
il a été utilisé pour des combats de
chien on dit est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est possible ce que vous avez la
réaction qu'elle a eu quand elle a vu
mes chiens
enfin laisse un gros doute sur
effectivement le fait qu'elle ait fait
des combats parce qu'elle enfin c'est
jeté elle était adorable et à partir du
moment où elle les a vu enfin je pouvais
quasiment plus la tenir en laisse elle
faisait des bons enfin elle voulait
vraiment les attaquer donc après je sais
pas réellement ce qui s'est passé mais
ça laisse des doutes c'est vous qui avez
contacté la Fondation c'est la mairesse
d'accord aujourd'hui donc elle est en
famille d'accueil le chien à la
Fondation elle est soignée par des
spécialistes puisqu'elle a besoin de
très gros soins qu'est-ce qu'ils disent
les spécialistes elle va alors elle va
s'en sortir ça c'est sûr il pense à de
la
faire de la chirurgie reconstructrice
pour pour essayer de faire quelque chose
elle a eu des séances de laser pour ses
yeux
ils ont un petit espoir qu'elle recouvre
un petit peu la vue donc sachant qu'elle
on pense qu'elle voyait un petit peu
parce que
je pense qu'elle voyait des ombres à
l'arrivait avoir quand on se déplaçait
et à nous suivait et ils ont un petit
espoir de récupérer un petit peu de sa
vision mais bon c'est on verra dans le
temps après
alors
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que ce chien on
l'a vu on sait pas du tout à qui il est
ce qui s'est passé
effectivement pas pucé patatouer
des appels à témoin qui ont été lancés
pour essayer de savoir à qui appartenait
ce chien et pour l'instant personne
n'arrive à trouver le propriétaire du
chien et puis un risque quand même qu'il
soit dangereux puisque il a été élevé
pour faire des combats de chiens
l'avenir est incertain pour le chien
donc attention ouais c'est ça
surtout celui qui a fait ce qui lui a
fait ça qui est un monstre je suis
désolé mais c'est complètement dépourvu
d'humanité pour considérer le chien
comme un objet qu'on peut brûler qu'on
peut jeter à la poubelle et j'espère
qu'il y aura des vrais sanctions déjà
pour dissuader les gens de faire ça
parce que malheureusement il y a trop de
gens qui se battent leurs chiens qui les
maltraite et surtout pour les protéger
la société de ces individus parce que
les gens qui tabassent les chats comme
ça c'est des gens dangereux avec tout le
monde avec les humains aussi il y a
plein de tueurs en série qui ont
commencé par maltraiter les animaux donc
il faut sanctionner ces mecs là qui sont
pardon mais des merdes et j'espère qu'il
vous diront en prison et longtemps un
exercice de sévices graves ou dates de
envers un animal domestique ou
apprivoisé c'est trois ans
d'emprisonnement et 45 minutes
qu'est-ce qui se passe après non ce
qu'il faut dire aux gens c'est que là
peut-être il y a quelqu'un qui va
peut-être reconnaître le chien et pas
forcément rester basé sur la commune de
montjavou parce que c'est un tout petit
village
même moi je pense que c'est même
quelqu'un qui l'a déposé là le chef
parce que je peux pas penser qu'il c'est
un chien qui vient ici c'est peut-être
un chien qui vient de banlieue même de
banlieue parisienne d'à côté et
peut-être que si quelqu'un reconnaît le
chien c'est vrai que moi pour moi c'est
pas c'est pas de manger à vous moi
j'avoue moi je connais c'est un tout
petit village il se passe quasiment rien
de voiture qui sont passées dans la
journée
[Musique]
notre chien tout le monde se connaît
donc c'est peut-être un chien qui vient
de loin et qu'on a déposé là comme ça
pour s'en débarrasser on va reconnaître
le propriétaire c'est pour ça donc
nombreuses de Régis sur l'animal souffre
de les brûlé sur le haut du crâne il a
de nombreuses bienfaits les paupières
découper on va voir les photos s'il vous
plaît regardez les photos de l'animal il
semblerait que l'animal il était donc je
vois pas quand il a été aspergé d'acide
je vois pas pourquoi on dit qu'il a été
il a fait des combats parce qu'il y a
pas un autre animal qui lui envoyer de
l'acide donc forcément c'est ça
des morsures de d'autres pro sur le
museau mais par ailleurs effectivement
il a peut-être fait des combats ce chien
mais par ailleurs il y a la main de
l'homme etc…
ils ont espoir avec des séances de laser
mais sans certitude sans certitude c'est
certitude
donc c'est vrai que elle est
actuellement donc comme vous l'avez dit
en soins
assistance aux animaux a pris en charge
la totalité des soins sont hébergement
va dire à sa meilleure réape adaptation
et remercie la personne qui l'a sécurisé
et qui nous a contacté aujourd'hui les
habitants ont également lancé un appel à
témoin afin de retrouver l'auteur de
cette barbarie l'animal n'est ni tatoué
ni pucé donc les propriétaires n'ont pas
pu être identifiés la Fondation apportée
plainte pour SEVIS grave et abandons et
met tout en oeuvre pour retrouver
l'auteur de cette barbarie nous
remercions toute personne susceptible de
nous aider à identifier ce criminel à
nous apporter ces témoignages vous avez
été interrogé par par la police pas du
tout non donc pour l'instant vous avez
pas pu dire vous l'avez retrouvé ou
votre maman l'a retrouvé etc je crois
que ma mère a été
à signaler l'endroit voilà la mais après
ils sont en train de c'est l'endroit
c'est où l'endroit parce que pour qu'on
sache un petit peu il y a des c'est
drôle
dans le 60 mais entre montjavou et
Valais cours
c'est à 30 km de Cergy-Pontoise donc
c'est vraiment des petits villages dans
le Vexin et on est très limitrophes du
95 du 27 voilà qui vient de là-bas
alors
les enquêteurs de la Fondation indiquent
qu'au vu des blessures du comportement
de la chaîne il est possible que
l'animal donc ait été utilisé pour faire
des combats cette chaîne environ à jeune
environ deux ans selon le vétérinaire a
subi le pire de ce que l'être humain
peut faire ses yeux ont été sévèrement
abîmés elle a perdu sa capacité visuelle
mais des pas totalement aveugles aspergé
d'acide une partie du visage détruit un
début de scalp et une veine tentative à
raccommoder ses paupières comme je vous
l'ai dit a été une fois les méfaits
exorciser par son tortionnaire largué
avec ses nécroses exposées à la
surinfection et encaissons les douleurs
de ces lésions corrosives le parquet de
Beauvais dit qu'une enquête a été
ouverte et que les investigations donc
se poursuivent donc on sera assez vite
voilà ce qui s'est passé en France on
espère et comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure Valérie bénigne les
propriétaires ou les personnes qui ont
fait ça risque jusqu'à 3 ans
emprisonnement et 45000 € d'amande alors
jusqu'à on dit toujours jusqu'à 3 ans
d'emprisonnement et 45000 € d'avant
Nicolas
ils ont même pas les 45000 € d'amende
donc ce qui est terrible effectivement
c'est que ce sont des criminels qui ont
maltraité un chien et que il ne risque
rien en réalité qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
comment et il faudrait d'abord il
faudrait retrouver mais le pire c'est
que si on les retrouve il ne risque pas
grand chose c'est le problème
[Musique]
c'est pas grave voilà vous allez pas
aller en prison vous allez pas payer
d'amende et heureusement qu'il y a les
fondations pour aider et pour faire
avancer parce que pardon on a
l'impression que la justice elle s'en
fout clairement moi ça me choque que
vous ayez pas peur à parler à la police
que que la police vous ai pas interrogé
qui fasse avancer l'enquête heureusement
qu'elle est fondation heureusement qu'il
y a des émissions pour en parler parce
que sinon on s'en fout c'est un chien on
s'en tape ben je suis désolé c'est
dégueulasse voilà alors est-ce que c'est
un chien de combat ou pas du tout où
est-ce qu'on le sait ça ou pas du tout
on n'en sait pas plus après c'est plus
l'association Le l'association elle
pense que c'est elle pense parce que
effectivement elle a remarqué sur le
museau des traces qui pourraient
correspondre à des traces de crocs d'un
autre chien auquel cas ça voudrait dire
que ce chien est habitué à se battre et
à recevoir des traces de des morsures
d'autres décalage entre son attitude
avec les humains
c'est quand même un indice mon travail
d'attaquer
il y a deux pistes dans l'enquête il y a
deux pistes il y a une première piste
qui serait que effectivement quelqu'un a
pris sa bagnole et a fait des kilomètres
pour les déposer là en se disant on
remontera pas ma piste ou alors ce chien
a réussi par une force incroyable et
passe par l'envie de survie à s'échapper
de quelque part et il faut trouver ce
quelque part qui sera pas loin pour le
coup tout à fait les deux pistes il faut
savoir quand elle a été récupérée là
dans cet état-là les vétérinaires nous
ont dit que ça faisait une à deux
semaines c'est ça c'est arrivé une à
deux semaines donc
et moi quand ma mère la récupérer elle
est montée dans la voiture elle était
remplie d'amour c'est incroyable la
confiance qu'elle a encore donné à
l'être humain elle était collée à ma
maman s'est senti sauvée
à la fin de son calvaire peut-être
humain
et beau